who are the first investors how did you
get that first seed round done uh that's
actually a really good story
so i'm asking we whoever they are
they're pretty stoked right now to be
investors in this company i hope they
are
uh we were you know we were going
through the like
the the grueling um pitching dozens and
dozens of uh
investors over a period of months
struggling to get any traction you know
this was especially in 2011 this was not
right after the financial crisis and
right after maker was sold whatever a
number of years earlier uh makerbot sold
several years after that oh sorry
they started a couple years before that
yeah they started a couple years before
that
but there was very little investment in
this sort of hardware company so we were
struggling to get anyone to
everyone you know came and saw demo the
printer working they said that's awesome
you guys seem really smart i have no
idea like what
this even is or how to invest in it or
anything like that that's the problem
with making something new
when it's that new it gets people
excited
but it also scares them from writing a
check yeah so what maniac gave you that
first check-in for how much
so we were like on literally the you
know the 50th
uh investor meeting something like that
um over
dinner at legal seafood in harvard
square yeah
and um uh going through the same lobster
probably crab louie yeah clam chowder
and uh
probably you know going through the same
pitch and we got to the end of dinner we
knew like we had done this enough times
to know this this one wasn't going
anywhere
and went back to the apartment that me
and my co-founder david craner were
living in
and he got an email
from a friend of ours with like a
retweet
of an original tweet the original tweet
from at m caper
and um you know clicked on and sell that
oh that's mitch caper we
vaguely you know know who he is and the
original tweet says
um on the patio at legal seafoods in
harvard square
uh overhearing two entrepreneurs
pitching 3d printing
anyone interested or something like that
whoa and um
this is a great story and we're like wow
that mitch caper of course the founder
of founders123 yeah founder of lotus
software and i think what's really
relevant for the story he was
part of the pc revolution he was part of
taking
mainframe expensive technology and
making it accessible part of making
killer apps for businesses
yeah so there's actually a lot big
parallels when it was pretty muddy
people were like oh we can buy a 5 000
pc now what do we do with it exactly it
was the same hobbyist thing so
uh so um you know i
i being a pessimistic skeptical engineer
i was just like laughed about it and
said okay you know whatever
uh but luckily david is a much more
opportunistic
uh guy and he said let's email him yeah
slide to the dms let's go
yeah and so he found his email address
sent him an email and
um send you a check that was awesome
actually first he wrote back he wrote
back somehow like in the middle of the
night i guess he was on
california time or something like that
and um
and he said um or he's a winner could be
i mean let's be honest people who email
back quickly
and take decisive action are winners and
people who disappear for three or four
days
they generally don't win as much that
might be me so i don't know you
disappear for four days and don't check
your email
for opportunities oh i i check it but i
i can be slow to
respond yeah i like to think about
things
really well see if you're an investor
you got to respond quick
yeah you got to seize the day i don't
think i'd be a good early stage investor
no
no probably so he wrote back right away
snooze you lose actually he wrote back
right away and said
um uh you know sounds interesting but i
know nothing about this so i won't
invest
so that that was his quick response
quick no yeah
now did you take it as a no or an
opportunity well he said yeah
let's talk next time i'm in town and uh
next time he was in boston
to to receive his star on the kendall
square
like tech uh walk of oh is there such a
thing yes
yeah oh yeah they're putting that up for
me in brooklyn yeah
it's like three famous people from
brooklyn yeah steven seagal me
ricky schroeder um so uh
so he came by uh came by our
our office and um uh
and you know you listen to the story and
by the end of it to paraphrase
um incorrectly mitch was like uh
you know this is just like it was when
we were inventing the pc
and like i want to get involved yeah and
uh
all of a sudden you got a hyundai 250 he
usually puts in a little 250.
uh yeah i think there's three hundred
thousand that's pardon yeah i know
at about the same time um uh joey ito
who was joining mit as director of the
media lab right um
where we came out of uh oh you were in
the media lab yeah yeah tell people what
the media lab is and
uh why people are so enamored with it
why you chose it to spend two or three
years of your life the media lab is
really
interesting unusual place i don't really
know it's a good one yeah
i don't really know any other place like
in the world so it's a
kind of a research department at um
at mit that has uh 20 30 professors and
like 150
grad students and what's
unusual about it one super
cross-disciplinary research there's
everything from like
biotech to like robots
making music and like everything between
3d printing
uh and another thing that's really
unusual about it is a good chunk of the
funding comes from the sort of corporate
sponsorship model where right
um it's been called a country club for
tech companies
they each put a million two million five
million in and that's the budget
yeah and then uh they they put it in
without a lot of constraints and then
the media lab sort of distributes it
amongst this professor so there's a lot
more flexibility a lot more open-ended
research
a lot it's generally centered around
like human computer interaction but but
really broad
yeah amazing tools amazing smart people
it's just fun to walk around the lab
i've been there many times where you
just walk around meet students and
they're working on their projects
and that's what the big microsoft's or
cisco's
writing checks do yeah they walk around
they get inspiration
they don't have ownership in the
projects but they get to meet you early
yep they get to meet early they have
some kind of ip license but that's
really they just want to be there yeah
uh so you were working on the 3d
printing there
uh not really i i was where
was your project uh i was in the part of
the media lab called the center for bits
and atoms
which is sort of like a hard tech group
there i'm sure that was nicholas
negroponte's thing because
his whole book being digital was the
seminal book i don't know if you
remember this you're a little younger
but
back in 1994 or five he wrote a book
called being digital and it was
basically the book you handed to people
who didn't understand what the internet
was or what the
possibility was here and he just
explained that atoms were going to be
turned into bits
yeah and that music was going to go from
a record to being bits
and books would be bits yeah stuff would
take for advantage now photos would be
bits movies would be beds and you could
move them
the professor i worked with neil
gershenfeld he was kind of one of the
early
early professors in the media lab who
had uh
who had really pushed that his kind of
whole research group is around
bits being more like atoms and atoms
being more like bits using things we
learned from
computation to change how we make things
so that's like what 3d printing
is um and also vice versa making
computation
reflect more how we make things um
anyway interesting topic
but i worked on joey had a fun so he
invested too
yeah he invested too um and uh
and with the with those two guys
involved then uh
they told us to go up on angel list
which was just like wow i was like
only a year old i think at the time yeah
um i was the first syndicate i mean
after naval like the internal syndicate
i was the first external syndicate yeah
yeah so we went up there at that point
it was just basically like a
like a profile page like there was no
page no linkedin
yeah no function to like support
investing um
and like you know people started rolling
in
after mitch and joey were were involved
and we ended up with uh
i think 16 different investors that was
mind-blowing at the time i guess
around here these days this is not
nothing special but like
to get to get like seen investors pretty
cool to do 45 well to do like a 45
minute call with some guy in japan
and then him wire like a hundred
thousand dollar check later that
yeah that i could not believe that uh
that that happens